[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه 60 برنامج
الالمانيه
عقول ايران تهجروها نحو بيئه اكثر
استقرارا الوسائل كثيره لكن الهدف واحد
والنتيجه داخل يعاني
وفي ملفات الساعه 60 الصين تعلن الاستقرار
وارقامه كرونات تناقضها تشونيون خطر جديد
وفي ازمه التغير المناخي هناك تكنولوجيا
من اجل الحل وهنا كتر اليونان مهتلاء
وهناك بالونات
[موسيقى]
الحرب الاوكرانيه وصلت لنقطه الفاصله هكذا
يرى حلف الناتو الوضع وهكذا يشير الواقع
على الارض روسيا تواصل التقدم والهجمات
الناجحات تستاهلها بقيادتي باليريج
راسموبا للعمليات اليوم سيطرت على مدينه
كيليشيتا بالقرب من محمود افيدونيس وعلى
اربع المناطق في مقاطعه سفروجها قبل ايام
سيطرت على بلده سول قبلها اعلن وزير
الدفاع وانه سينفذ توجيهات بوتن لاجراء
اصلاحات عسكريه واسعه النطاق بين 2003
و 2026 والهدف توسيع القوات المسلحه
الروسيه على الا استعدادا لحربا طويله
الامد في اوكرانيا
الاصلاحات تشمل زياده عدد الافراد
العسكريين الروس الى مليون ونصف المليون
جندي من مليون و350 الف لحاليا وامامها
هذه الحقائق باتت زياده الدعم الغربي
لاوكرانيا ضروريه ولذلك اجتمع وزراء ودفاع
حلف الناتو في قاعده رامشتاين في المانيا
واوكرانيا التي اعلنت التاهب الجوي في
جميع انحاء البلاد طلبت الغرب بالمزيد من
الاسلحه تحديدا الدبابات وسنتطرق لذلك
لاحقا يرد وزير الدفاع الامريكي
ليش ليش
هذه مرحله حاسمه لاوكرانيا ومرحله صعبه من
الحرب نحن جميعا ندعم دفاع اوكرانيا عن
اراضيها مهما ترى الامر وسنحافظ على زخم
المساعدات العسكريه الاوكرانيا نعلم ان
روسيا مستمر في اعتداءتها وزادت من كثافه
هجماتها الصاروخيه التي طالت ارواح
الابرياء الاوكران وشاهدنا وحشيه ذلك قبل
ايام في مدينه
نيروت
تقدموا حزمه مساعدته
ان الولايات المتحده
اوكرانيا
كانت مخزنه في اسرائيل
لتستخدمها اوكرانيا في الحرب والعهده هنا
على نيويورك
الامر واقر به مسؤول اسرائيلي قال لرويتر
ستقريبا النحو 300,000 قذيفه مدفعيه من
عيارين 155 ملم وهذا الدعم الغربي الكبير
والامريكي تحديدا لاوكرانيا اللقاء عليه
الكريم لان اليوم ستدخلنا بشكل مباشر في
الحرب ودباباتكم اللانت توقفنا عن تحقيق
اهدافنا على العموم اجانب الدعم العسكري
ياتي مع دعم واشنطن الاستخباراتيه
اليوم الى ان مدير السياحيه سافر الى
اوكرانيا السره الاسبوع الماضي والتقى
الرئيس الاوكرانيه
ايه ده كان الدعم الغربي لاوكرانيا ساعدها
ويساعدها لمقاومه الهجمات الروسيه فهو
جاءك طريقه لاختبار الاسلحه الغربيه في
ساحه المعركه هناك نجوم لمعه واخرى افلات
مدافع والهاضر مثلا كبيره وفقيله تعملوا
ضمن معدات المدفعيه الاخرى في مجموعه تسمى
البطاريات يجب على المدافع اطلاق النار
والانطلاق بسرعه من خلال ربطها بعربه الجر
والانتقال الى موقع جديد لتجنب رد العدو
على اطلاق النار قائدو امريكي اكد لسي ان
ان انا حاول اصبح من الماضي سلاح اخر
طائره الدعم الجوي القريب الفعاله بفضل
طيران هذه بطئ وعلى ارتفاعات المنخفضه
اوكرانيا معركه طائرات الدعم الجويه
القريب
اذا تم استخدامها في خط المواجهه ضد عدونا
لديه دفعه جويه حديثه
على الجانب الروسي سنبدا من النجاح
مسيراته لانسيت ثلاثه الانتحاريه توفر
لموسكو وميزه هامه القدره على ايجاده وضرب
احداث متحركه مثل صواريخ هاي مارس من مدن
بعيد وعلى عكس الصاروخ التقليدي او الموجه
او الموجه يمكن للمسيره الانتحاريات عن
فطيره عشوائيه بحثا عن اهداف الدهون تحدي
موقعها بشكلنا مسبق مع هذه الاسلحه توجد
الدبابات طبعا وهي فخ الموت الان وهكذا
يصفها من الان ماسك الذي يستمر في اثاره
الجدل وتعليقه جاءنا على تغريده من مصمم
لالعاب الفيديو
الذي تساءلت عن فعاليه الدبابات في القتال
الحديث تزامنا مع شحنه مساعدات العسكريه
جديده لاوكرانيا ينتظر تتضمن مركبات
المدرعه احد ردود البارزه ايضا على تغريده
ماسك جاء من مارك هارت لينك وهو القائد
العام الاسبق للجيش الامريكي في اوروبا
هارتلينج اكد ان نظريه ماسك تكون صحيحه في
حاله واحده اذا كانت لديك دبابات سيئه
الطقم غير مدربه قياده سيئه اما في
السيناريو المعاكس فهيات توفروا امكانيه
البقاء على قيد الحياه لطاقمها وميزه
كبيره في ساحه المعركه كل هذه التعليقات
اثاره شكوكا حول اقتراب انقراض الدبابات
العسكريه بشكلها الحالي من اراد الميدان
وذلك بسبب سهوله الاستهداف لكن رغم ذلك
تطلب اوكرانيا المسيده منها رغم توفر بدل
بتكنولوجيا متقدمه واسلحه بتقنيه فائقه
لكنها غير مستخدمه لحسب واشنطن بوست لدرجه
جعلت الحرب الح في اوكرانيا تشبه الحرب
العالميه الاولى
معركه بخمود كذلك على الاقل وهنا مشاهدينا
نعود بالزمن الى حرب الخنادق اما في الحرب
العالميه الثانيه فهناك تشابه اخر فكره
البحث عن غناء امرا طبيعي في الحروب لكن
الحربين تشابها في اصلاح هذه الغنائم
والاستفاده منها على ارض المعركه مجددا في
اكتوبر الماضي مثلا اقدرت الاستخبارات
البريطانيه ان اكثر من نصف اسطول الدبابات
الاوكرانيه يتكون من مركبات روسيه تم
الاستلاء عليها فعلى البريطانيون الشيء
نفسه بعد معركه العلمين علم الحميميه وجد
الحلفاء على الثوره اكثر من مليون حاويه
بترول المانيا واكثر من 50 الف بندقيه
وثلاثه الاف رشاش اصلحوها واستخدمها في
معركهم لكن اني ماذا استخدام الاليات
القديمه رغم امكانيات التطور التكنولوجيه
الحالي للاسلحه والمعدات المفترض ان يتم
تعلم الفرق
الاستخباراتيه والعسكريه بشكل متزامنا اي
تنسيق لها جماعه اسلحه المشاه المدرعات
المدفعيه والمهندسين والطيران والقدرات
المشتركه الاخرى بشكل فعال في مهمه واحده
امرنا فشلت موسكو في تحقيقه بشكل كبير
مثلا لم يتلقى الجنود الروس واجزاء من
انظمه اثار للاتصالات للوحدات الموجوده
على الارض الحصول على المنظومه كامله فقط
يضمن الفاعليه وبالتالي لجات روسيا لاجهزه
صينيه تجاريا زاهده الثمن وخرائط صممت قبل
عقود وذلك بحسب واشنطن بوستينز لكن على
عكس موسكو نجحت ولو نسبيا في رب بيلاتي
والمعلومات الاستخباراتيه ودمجها وتحليلها
على سبيل المثال جمعت المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه من مصادر مفتوحه مثل حسابات
المجلدين على مناصات الوسائل وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي لتحديد مواقع التشكيلات
العسكريه
للخاصمه اذن وتحدثنا عن الاسلحه
التكنولوجيه الحديثه غير المستخدمه بشكل
الفعال في الحرب لكن ماذا سيكون شكل
الحروب في المستقبل
سناخذكم في جوله
نحن في عام 2050 بالنسبه لواشنطن التهديد
الاكبر بات الحرب الالكترونيه ولم يعد
الحرب التقليديه او الحرب النوويه نعم الا
يمكننا تحديد شكل الميادين القتال
مستقبلنا لكن بالنظر لنجاحات المسيرات في
اكثر من حرب واخرها في اوكرانيا تطور
الجيوش تطور الجيوش الكبرى منها وتطور
مدرعات وطائرات مقاتله غير ماهوله بل انها
طائرات قد تزيح المركبات الماهوله بشكل
كامل بحلول منتصف القرن الجاري سلاح جديد
قد يغيره قواعد الاشتباك النظام الدفاع
الامريكي بالليزر سيفعل ما لم يفعله اي
نظام سلاح الليزر كهربائي ارضي من قبل هذا
ما صاروخين من الصواريخ وعلى عكس الانظمه
الحركيه التقليديه مثل المدفعيه فهذا
النظام لا ينفع الرص منه ابدا اما الجندي
الخارق الذي نراه في افلام يهوليود قد
نراه كجزءا محوري من الجيش الامريكي بحلول
عام 2050 بحسب البنتاجون المميزاته كثيره
لكن منها القدره السمعيه الهامه للغايه في
ساحه القتال جنود اليوم يرتدون حمايه اذن
لالغاء الضوضاء لفحص معدات ولوازم الاسلحه
وحمايه الاذن النسبيا حيث يعاني تعرض
وتعرض الكثير منها وستكون سماعات الراس
الصغيره مفيده للغايه اما جنود المستقبل
سيمتلكون نطاق اكبر من السمع والحمايه من
فقدان السمع النقطه الاكثر اثاره هي
الترابط العقلي العصبي للافكار بين جنود
الجيش الواحد ما يسيح مشاركه المعلومات
بشكل فوري لمساعده انظمه الكمبيوتر
والمسرات المسؤوله عن جمع المعلومات
بالعوده للواقع الان والحديث عن وصول
الحرب الاوكرانيه لنقطه فاصله فاي هجوم
اوكراني مضاد سيتطلب الان دبابات القتال
حديثه بريطانيا اعلنت ارسال تشالنجر اثنين
واشنطن تدرسه
ابرامز لكن تبقى لي قاد الالمانيه الاكثر
افاده لكي لماذا
تستخدم المحرك التوربيني الغازي عيبه
استهلاكه الكبير للغاز والجيش الاوكراني
لا يمتلك الكثير من الشاحنات الوقود مثل
الجيش الامريكي اما لا يطارد فتعتمد على
محرك تربونيه يعمل
مقارنه مع تشالنجر البريطانيه
لندن 2007 دبابات سترسل لاوكانيا 14 بينما
تمتلك الدول الاوروبيه
وبالتالي دعم اكبر من ناحيه العدد
ليبارد اثنين اربعه هي الاقدم بين كل
النسخ التي لا تزال في الخدمه لكنها تظل
اكثر تطورا من الدبابات السوفياتيه
القديمه التي تستخدمها اوكرانيا مثل التي
72 والتي تعاني قصورا تحديدا من ناحيه
الذخيره الخاصه بها 125 ملمترا لم تعد
تنتج حاليا في اوروبا وهي ميزه اخرى
لانها دخيلتها من عيال 120 مليمترا يتم
انتاجه في اوروبا حاليا وليوفره مشاهدينا
هذه الميزه قد تتحول الى عيب بسبب مساله
الامداد طويل الاجل نعم اخيرا الدبابات لا
تستهلك بنفس الكميات مثل ذخيره المدفعيه
لكننا الوتيره وتيره الحرب وامكانيه ان
تكون اطول
تتطلب من المانيا تسريع انتاجي ذخيره
الدبابات وامر تعاني منه برلين اصلا في ما
يخص المدفعيه وواحدا من اسباب الانتقادات
التي طالت او وزيره الدفاع السابقه
المستقيله لكن هناك ازمه اخرى ستؤثر على
تسليم ليبارد اثنين لاوكرانيا لن يكون
بمقدار برلين تسليم الدبابه الى كيف الا
في عام 2024
الشركه المصنعه تؤكد ذلك واتعزل الامر
لتطويرها لكن هل هذا هو الواقع ام انها
منى وراسيه من المانيا وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيه ديترو كوليبا تحدث صادقا على
السياسه الالمانيه اولا يقولون لا ثم
يدافعون بشده عن قرارهم فقط ليقولون نعم
في النهايه تكرر الامر في ازمه الطاقه
ويتكرر الان لكن
اكثر من سيد دبابه في حوزه اثنا عشر جيشا
اوروبيا فهل تستطيع هذه الدول تسليم كياب
الدبابه دون موافقه برلين
العقود المبرمات الزم هذه الدول بموافقه
المانيا قبل تزويد الجيش الاوكراني بها
ثانيا لم تتلقى المانيا طلبات حتى الان
بهذا الصدد كما ترفض ضغوط الحلفاء وتضعوا
شرطا اساسيا للتسليم وهو ان تسلم واشنطن
هي الاخرى دبابات ابرام سلكيا لكن اللافت
ان الحكومه الالمانيه اليوم خرجت لتناقض
نفسها لم نربط الامرين ببعضهم
تعاونا وتنسيق للخلفاء مثلا خلافه وزراء
دفاع نيته اليوم لم يتوصلوا لقراءه
شوف الدنيا تعال هم بيعاقبان
دليل على وجود الخلاف يا بولندا مثلا التي
تؤكد انها لا تحتاج لضوء ابرين الاخضر
واليوم خليجيات وارسو صعدت اكثر ملوحه
باجراء غير تقليدي انعرضت المانيا الامر
الحلفاء اذا يضغطون على المانيا تماما كما
تضغط عليهم المعارضه في الداخل ضغطا جعل
وزيره الدفاع السابقه تستقيل ومن حل بدلا
عنها رجل من نفس الحزب لكن هناك اختلاف قد
يفجر ازمه جديده الوزير الجديد مؤيد ابن
روسيا
لم تصمد وزيره الدفاع الالمانيه كريستينا
لمروجت في منصبها اكثر من عام واحد فالمه
التي سلمها اياها المستشار الالماني اولاف
شونس تبين او تحولت الى مهمه صعبه ومتعبه
عكس ما كانت تتخيل لمرش عندما وافقت على
العدول عن التقاعد والتسلل حقيبه الدفاع
ولكن الحرب في اوكرانيا حولت هذه الوزاره
الى واحده من اهم الوزارات داخل الحكومه
الالمانيه خاصه بعد قرار المستشار اعاده
تاهيل الجيش الالماني الهرم لكي يمكنهم من
مواجهه اي اعتداءنا ضد المانيا فشلت
لمبرجيست بالمهمه سريعا والتهمت بالبطئ
وعدم فهم حاجات الجيش الالماني وحتى
التغيب عن العمل لاسباب خاصه فاستقالت
امام الانتقادات والضغوط المتزايده حل
مكانها سريعا وزير داخليه ولا ساكسونيا
السفلى بوليس بيس توريوس الذي تقع على
عاتقه الان مهمه اعاده تاهيل الجيش
الالماني واستمرار التسليح الجيش
الاوكراني بالعتاد والاسلحه والدبابات
الالمانيه الصنع التي تطالب بها كياف ولكن
تصريحات دستوريوس السابقه ومواقفه من
روسيا خاصه لجهه دعوته قبل ثلاثه سنوات
لرفع العقوبات عنها قد تعودوا لتطارده
وتعقده من مهمته هو ايضا
المزيد في هذا الملف ينضم الينا من لندن
روبرت فوكس المحلل العسكري اهلا بك اذا
كما في كل الحروب هناك اسلحه تنجح واخرى
تفشل لكن نظرا الى الحرب التي تقترب من
عامها الاول الان هناك من يرى ان هذه
الاسلحه هذه التكنولوجيا متاخره جدا في
حرب في عام 2023 الكثير من الخبراء يشبهون
الاحتياجات العسكريه في هذه الحرب الى
احتياجات الحرب العالميه الاولى
بوب سامسونج
دقيقه
من خلال هذه الاسلحه الدقيقه يوفر ذخيره
لكن الروس استخدم الكثير من الطلقات
اوكرانيا قديمه
عقد لكن الروسيا تضع همم
في هذه الحرب وهي حرب لبوتن هو من ينجح
وهو من سيخسر ولكن اذا تحدثنا عن التناغم
بين الاسلحه يعني الاستطلاع نجح بشكل لافت
في الحرب الاوكرانيه هذه المعلومات عبر
صور الاقمار الصناعيه نجحت بشكل واضح على
الجانب الاوكراني ولكن حتى تحدثنا عن
الجانب الروسي الا يعتبر هذا التناغم مع
التاهي بالتكنولوجيا المتقدمه في الاسلحه
هذا تناغم غير موجود على الارض مثلا في
الدبابات روسيا 72 على سبيل المثال يعني
الان همم روسيا تحاول اصلاح هذا الخلل رغم
انه
ظهر في حرب افغانستان
يا برنس
كما قلت فان نظرنا الى الاقتتال الاخير
فحسب ما فهمنا في صالوداد وباخوث
روسيا وخاصه وقوه
البشريه
التصريحات الاخيره من رمشتاين حيث يلتقي
وزراء الدفاع ومزودين همم
اوكرانيا وخاصه اجتماع
استماع القوات المشتركه في تالين سمعنا
كثيرا عن الدبابات
البريطانيه وبعض السلاح البريطاني لكن
هناك
تركيز على الرادار
حرب السيبرانيه
والستلايت كل هذه المسائل تش اهي خطوه
للامام
وتعطي تقدما
للقوات الاوكرانيه وروسيا
هل فعلا قعدت بناء قواتها في هذا الاطار
ايضا هذا سؤال مطروح لعلى العموم سيضرب
روبرت بوكس سنبقى بعيد جدا عن
يتحدث عنه الدول تحديدا امريكا تتحدث عن
تقنيات متطوره جدا انك الجندي يعني الذي
يستطيع ان يطور مهاراته من خلال الذكاء
الاصطناعي الى درجه
توفير الطاقه والى درجه عدم همم تعرض الى
اذى في الحروب اشكرك جزيل الشكر كنت معنا
من لندن روبرت فوكس المحلل العسكري
[موسيقى]
شعرت ان احلامي لن تتحقق الا بالمغادره
ايرانيه تروي المها بسبب الهجره في الساعه
بعد دقيقه
في ايران تكثر الاسباب التي تدفع المواطن
الى مغادره البلاد فالوضع المعيشي
والاقتصادي صعب ونظام يواجه الاحتجاجات
ضده بالقمع والقتل الهجره وسيله للهرب لكن
النظام يقف عائقا ايضا ونظمته تقييم
التعليم قررت تعليق اختباري ايلتس حتى
نهايه مارس القادم هذا القرار سيمنع
الطلاب من الاختبار الدوليا والمعني
بتحديد مستوى اللغه الانجليزيه كشرتا
لدخول الجامعه الاجنبيه
امتحان التوفل والجي ار اي وهما امتحانات
حميدهما الجامعات الدوليه لقبول الطلاب من
مختلفها انحاء العالم والاستكمال الخطه
رفعت قبل حوالي شهر التكلفه تكلفه تحرير
المؤهلات العلميه
للخريجين عده اضعاف من درجه الزملاء الى
الدكتوره المتخصصه والمهنيه في الجامعات
الحكوميه وترجمه الشهادات والمستندات
الهامه ما كان يكلف الالاف اصبح بعشرات
الملايين التومنات والوضع الاقتصاديه اصلا
من سيئا الى اسوء والعمله في ابي حالتها
وفي مستوى هبوط القياسي امام الدولار لكن
على ما يبدو ان هذه القرارات لن تثني
الشباب عن الهجره خصوصا بعد تعديل اسعار
الشهادات والذي عقبه انخفاض كبير في
التسجيل على امتحانات الماجستير والصوره
تبدو اقرب من داخل بيانات مرصد الهجره
الايراني العام الماضي سجلت الاحصاءات
143,000 حاله اللجوء المانيا كانت الوجهه
الرئيسيه احتضنته اللاجئين الايرانيين في
عام 2021
طوفان الهجره يعني ان هناك بيئه طارده
والبطاله من اهم الاسباب بالنسبه لطالب
العلم والمهن التخصصيه بمقارنه صغيره تدلل
على ما نقول في 2021 اشارك
66,000 طالب في امتحان القبول شهاده
الماجستير هذا العدد قل ولم يتجاوز ال
500,000 في 2022
كاس هذه الارقام هشاشه المنظومه التعليميه
والمؤسسيه منذ
1979 وتفسره ايضا محاولات النظام الحثيثه
لعكسها وان باساليب التعجيز كما ذكرنا
دليل اخر على هذه الحقائق ايران وصلت
للمرتبه الرابعه عالميا في هجره طلاب
الدكتوره الاوائل الى امريكا حيث يبقى 90%
من الخريجين في امريكا وبهذه النسبه قد لا
يكون هناك اخرجنا في المستقبل والتحذير من
منظمه الرعايه الصحيه في ايران
القلق ليس فقط من نقص الكفاءات الطبيه
والتمريض والهندسه ولكن ايضا من نقص
العماله الذي يمثل تحديا خطرا في ايران
والخوف من ان تتحول طائره جائحه وهنا وجبت
توقف عند هذا الرقم
وعشرون الفا هو عدد الاطباء من اصل ايراني
الذين يعملون في الولايات المتحده منهم
8000 طبيبا وجراح مجموعهم عادل نحو سته
وعشرين في المئه من العاملين الايرانيين
في قطاع الرياح رعايه الصحيه الامريكيه في
عام
عاما والتصريحنا لمسؤول الرعايه الصحيه
محمد رئيس ساده
فالمخصصون مثلا في مجال جراحه القلب قال
لا عددهم كثيرا في وقتا اصبحت امراض القلب
الاكثر شيوعا بين الشباب لكن مجال الطب
اليس الوحيد الذي يهاجر منه المتخصصه
[موسيقى]
سلطان
انا
اذا هما الهجره واللجوء وسائل وتبديل
الواقع والمستقبل في ايران لكن لدى الاوفر
حظا من الايرانيين طرقا اخرى
يلجا اليها الراغبون في الحصول على تذكره
خروج
2020 اسست
1961 الشركه في تركيا بمساهمه مهاجرين
ايرانيين قدرت قيمتها بنحو 22 مليون دولار
وخلال الاثنين 10 السنه الماضيه تم اصدار
البيت تاشيره لشركه ناشئه للايرانيين
افيدول مثل امريكا والمملكه المتحده لكن
حتى هؤلاء لا يسلمون من بطش النظام ان
تقوم واطراف الحكوميه بمحاولتي تجنيدهم
لمصلحه السلطات الامنيه بطريقه الترغيب
والترهيب
ومره والامر ايضا
على العقول المهاجره كخلايا نائمه تبرم
الحكومه عقود عمل مع خبراء مغتربين بحجه
تغطيه العجز الرسمي في الداخل والحقيقه
كما كشف الاعلام التركي ان المخطط تنفيذ
عمليات اغتيال لصالح الدوله
[موسيقى]
في داخل اول خارج الخطر يلاحق الايرانيين
وهذا ما يفسر ظاهره النفور او الهجره
الجماعيه التي لم تعد تقصر على الخامات
العلميه فقط العام الماضي انتشرت قصه
الارتفاع الجنوبي لمعادل مبيعات المنازل
في اكثر من منطقه تصنف راقيه ظاهره قلبت
مفاهيم حصرت سابقا حصلت سابقا الهجره على
المقامات العلميه دون غيرها في ايران
الهجره السنويه وصلت ايضا لرياضيين
الفنانين مثقفين كتاب مدرسين
كما ارتفعت بشكل كبير حالات الهجره
القصريه خلال السنوات الاخيره ما بين 20
الى 30 كشخص يفقدون كل عام ينقطع تنقطع
اخبارهم وتبقى مصائرهم مجهوله والبعض يفقد
اوراقه الثبوتيه بسبب الطرق غير القانونيه
الوعره التي يضرون لخوضها ما السبب تظهر
الاحصاءات العالميه ان معدل الدخل المواطن
العادي في العديد من الدول الاجنبيه يفوق
عشرات اضعاف اما يتقاضاه المواطن
الايرانيه في بلاده والهجره للجميع اذا
امر يظهره استطلاعه رايا لمركزي وانا
ليزيكس رغبه الايرانيين في الهجره تفوقوا
المتوسط العالمي به مرتين ليست رغبه فقط
بل واقع فنحو 17 في المئه هي حصه
الايرانيين مثلا في تركيا في 2020 و 2021
من المنازل التي اشتراها الاجانب والهجره
خلال الفتره القادمه قد تصل لمستوى الغير
التنبؤاتنا وفقا للادله المبعثره
والمنسجمه المعتمده على دراسات مدنيه
قليله تفيد باننا نتجه للوصول الى احدى
قمم الهجره ليس لدينا تقدير على الاطلاق
كم من الوقت سنكون في تلك الدروع اعتقد ان
موجه الهجره هذه المره ستكون غير مسبقه
مقارنه بالعقود القليله الماضيه وحتى
مقارنه بما قبل الثوره ستكون هذه الهجره
غير مسبوقه
صفر كانت موضوع
القريبه لكنه اخيرا عكس الاتجاه هو فتح
البر الرئيسيين لا حاجه بعد الحشر الصحي
لكن السؤال هلا رغبه الرئيس الصيني في ذلك
ام الطره اليك ربما ياتي الجواب من هنا في
اقصى الجنوب من مركز الصناعات التحويليه
في البلاد هذه المقاطعه الاقتصاديه
المهنيه دونجا
22 مليار دولار اعلى مكافحه كورونا فقط
خلال ثلاث سنوات لما يكون المبلغ بسيطا
اذا ما قررناه بميزانيه تطوير صناعه
الرقائق الالكترونيه التي ادشن
اذارته
مليار دولار في عام 2014 والتي يخص ساطع
كي تنافس واشنطن في هذا المجال على الساحل
الشرقي وعند مصبي نهر ينقصطي مثال اخر
مدينه شنغهاي مركز الصين المليء بناتج
المحلي يعادل الناتج المحلي لبولاندا في
2021 عانت هي الاخرى في سنوات كورونا في
ابريل وما يوم من عام 2021 تصبب انتشار
الفيروس باغلاق الشامل تضرر على اثره اكبر
ميناء في العالم بحصه تبلغ 20% من
الحلويات العالميه
مبيعات السيارات سجلت اصفارا طوال شهر
ابريل وهي بالفارقه موطننا المصانع
السيارات كثيره عالميه منها
ضربه الاقتصاديه الموجعه
او الهويه الانفاق على مكافحه الوباء في
منطقه
حيث واكبر مصنعه الرقائق مثل تي اس ام سي
واس ام اي سي يا انفقت المقاطعه قرابه ال
700 مليون دولار في 2022 رقم تجاوز مخصصات
الرعايه الصحيه العامه للمناسبات مع كل
هذه المعطيات كانت النتيجه ان الاقتصاد
الاكبر في العالم سجلات تراجع عن قياسيا
التراجع ملحوظه جدا فطلبات تدخل سريعا
وهنا جاء القرار الغاء سياسه صفر ضد التي
دفع عنها الرئيس الصيني كثيره الالغاء على
التوقعات تشير الى انتعاش اقتصادي لا يقل
عن خمسه في المئه خلال العام الحالي لكن
المجازفه كبيره كما تختار الجديده مع بدء
عوده الحياه لطبيعتها واولها احتفال
الصينيون بالعام القمري الجديد وثانيها
يتحول الجديد الذي لا يؤمن بالعطر ورغم
اعلان الصين اليوم التغلب على تفشي كورونا
مع ايام شونيون لكن الغاء صفر كوبد
والمتحول الجديد ابهر العكس 60 الف وفاء
بكرونا خلال خمسه اسابيع اما هناك في
الثالث اكبر مقاطعه كثافه بالسكان تحديدا
افيخ نانه بين كل عشره هناك تسعه اصيبوا
نتحدث عن 88
ونصف مليون شخص ولا نعلم كيف ومتى
طبعا لان المتحور الجديد دورونا في ذلك
لكنه حتى الان يكتنفه بعد الغموض لا نعلم
ان هو خليط من متحورين اخرين من متحولات
اوميكرون الصين متحفظه عن نشر اي تفاصيل
حتى لمنظمه الصحه العالميه التي تلح عليها
بمشاركه معلومات عن المتحور الاكثر
عن حتى الان
تحفظ الصين اخلق اوروبا وامريكا شركه
البيانات الصحيه البريطانيه تتوقع 36,000
وفى يوميا بدءا من الاسبوع المقبل ولذلك
اشتركت بريطانيا رفقه فرنسا وايطاليا ودول
اخرى اشترطت اجراء اختبار
القادمين اقصى الشرق بكين اعترضت وقالت
انها تبحث عن حل يبقى الحضر كما نبهنا
ضروريا قبل خاصه في هذه المرحله يبدو ان
اجزاء مسلسل كورونا مستمره والوضع يتطلب
استجابه للتحديات القادمه
ستايل
[موسيقى]
ايوه
من هذه التحديات وجهه وامريكا ودول
الاوروبيه والمتحول بدا ينتشر هناك وبسرعه
وما بارقام المطلقه ربما لم يصل الوضع لي
خطوره ما يحصل في الصين حيث المستشفيات
بالمرضى ودور الجنازات بالجزر لكن الصور
قد تتكرر والتشاءم مبرر امريكا معرضه لنقص
ان ذاتها الطبيه والعهده هنا على صيام
مصنع العالم الصيني طبعا
تعرضه وان كانت خفيفه
فتكرار العمال الصينيين لحملات الاضراب
والتقاطهم للعدو اي يهدد
والسلاسل التوريد التي تمتلك الصين الحصه
الاكبر منها عالميا تعطل المكينه البشريه
الصينيه يؤثر على العالم فالصين لا تزالوا
اكبر مصدر للاقنعه والقفازات والارضيات
الطبيه حتى مكونات الادويه الاساسيه اذا
كانت الولايات المتحده وحدها استوردت
ادويه من الصين بقيمه ثلاثه مليارات
ومئتين مليون دولار
مادام
بقدو في فرنسا مثلا لا يتجاوز عدد الادويه
المصنعه على اراضيها العشرين في المئه
الباقي ياتي من الخارج والغالبي تاتي من
الصين وفي بريطانيا واحده من كل سته
مواطبيه حيويه مستخدمه في المستشفيات تاتي
من الصين وذلك بحسب لتحقيق انه شرف مايو
مثال اخر خلال الربيع الماضي اضطر اطباء
امريكيون اللي هي تاجيل عمليات جراحيه بعد
تاخر وصول 10 الاف
امريكا واوروبا من ما حصل
وركزت على الانتاج المحلي وها هي ستون في
المئه من الشركات التصنيع تسارع لاستبدال
خياراتها بالهند
كل هذا القلق ياتي تزامن ان مع اكبر حركه
بشريه في العالم
وهكذا هي الصين حتى في اعيادها تظهر قوتها
البشريه فيما يعرف بيتشونيون الصينيه اي
حركه الربيع هذه النقاط توضح كيف بدا
الصينيون بالانتشار النشاط
الى 400 مليون مهاجر للاحتفال بالسنه
القمريه الجديده العمال والطلاب حزموا
الامتعه على ان يلحقهم الموظفون بيت
العائله هو الوجه الاخيره اما البعض الاخر
فاختاره ان يقضي اجازته خارج البلاد بعد
ثلاث سنوات من الاغلاق رسميا ينطلقوا
العيد الوطني غدا في الحادي والعشرين من
يناير يستمر لسبعه ايام لكن الهجره
الواسعه تستمر لاسابيع 40 يوما تحديدا
بدات في السابع من يناير وتنتهي في الحادي
والعشرين من فبراير وهنا الخطا اذا ان
الهجره تجري في ظل انتشار الفيروس ومتحوله
الجديد اي ان الصين تخاطر بالفتح وتعرض
اقل من ربع سكان العالم مقاليا لخطر
العدوى من ربما تخاطر لنشر العدوى في كل
بقاع الارض توفقا لتوقعاتي وزاره النقل
ستجرى نحو ثلاثه مليارات رحله داخليه
وخارجيه خلال احتفالات هذا العام ومعظمها
تسجل حركه مغادره
وحركه دخول وخروج من والى بكين المخاطر
الكبرى تتعلق بالمسنين الحلقه الاضعف في
في مواجهه الفيروس فالهجره تجريف المناطق
الحضريه الى الريفيه الاقل تجهيزا باسره
العنايه واجهزه التنفس حيث يقصن غانبيات
كبار السن بالغ عددهم رئتين والخمسين
مليون
[موسيقى]
من البراكين فكره ثوريه لمكافحه تغير
المناخ سناخذكم في جوله عبر الواقع المعزز
في الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد العام ولا اكثر سخونه
بتاريخ الارض كان هذا عام
بحسب ناسه العام الماضي وجدته الحر الشديد
في الولايات المتحده واوروبا الفيضانات
المدمره في باكستان نيجيريا السودان
وغيرها ملايين المتضررين من عمل زاد فيه
الاحتباس قسوه لكن من ينظر به العام
الجديد بيناير دافئ النسبيا غير مسبوق
استهلته اوروبا بمظاهر الشابه نتجت عن
ارتفاع الحراره 8 درجات عن المعدلات
الطبيعيه
منتجعات التزلج في جبال الالف اغلقت بسبب
قله الثلوج وهناك من يستمتع في الشواطئ
على شواطئ اسبانيا وايطاليا اذا الصيف
يحمل توقعات اسواق ليس التوقعات الساعه 70
بالتاكدات علماء المناخ لكن لماذا
الاجابه في النينو ظاهره مناخيه ستزيد
الطينه بالله تحدث عندما تصبح المياه في
شرق المحيط الهادئ الاستوائي دافئه بشكل
غير طبيعي اللي تؤثر على دوران الغلاف
الجوي العالمي هي تحدث كل بضع سنوات كانت
المره الاخيره في 2016 غير انها هذا العام
قد ترفع درجه حراره الارض الى الدرجه غير
المرجوئه فماذا لدينا من خيارات الان
وماذا نملك من ادوات التعايش ولا شيء اخر
لكن التعايش لا يعني الاهمال هناك ستبير
تدبير التكيف مثل جعل البنيه التحتيه اكثر
مقاومه
للفيضانات مثلا لكن ماذا لو لم يحرك ساكن
لو وقفت الدول متفرجه تجيب شركات تاديلوي
تابي دراسه الصادمه لكن دقيقه الاقتصاد
العالمي سيتكبد تكاليف في 178 تريليون
دولار بحلول عام 2070 تكلفه بشريه
ناتجه عن نقص الغذاء الماء وفقدان الوظائف
وتدهور الصحه والرفاهيه وفي المقابل
والعمل المناخي يمكن ان يحقق ثلاثه
واربعين ترليون دولار من صافي القيمه
الحاليه لعباره اخرى اذا تحركنا الان
فسنحقق مكسبا تحول الاقتصادي والحد من
الاثار الكارثيه لتغيير المناخ
اتعايش يتطلب الكثير يحتاجون مكافحه تغير
المناخ وانقاذ الكوكب كان نسكن بجانب
بركان ونبني حصن يحمينا من حمامه او ان
نستفيد من انفجاره
سنعيدكم الى عام
1991 بركان جبلي بنابو في الفلبين يثور
الاف والاطماني من ثاني اكسيد الكبريت
تطلق في طبقه الاستراتوسفير فاينخفض متوسط
درجات الحراره العالميه بنحو درجه
الان البيت الابيض بصددي تنسيق خطه بحثيه
مدتها خمس سنوات وليس لتفجير البراكين
للمصادقه على مشروع مستوحى من انفجارها
برنامج يبرد الارض بمقدار درجه واحده
مئويه تكلفته اقل من عشره مليارات دولار
سنويا رخيصه مقارنه بتقنيه التخفيف الاخرى
والتريليونات التي تحدثنا عنها قبل قليل
شركه
الشمس ستصنع غيوم عاكسه على ارتفاعات
عاليه قابله للتحلل للحيوان تبرد الكوكب
وتكبح الاحترار العالمي الكارثي
العمليه اسمها تحسين البياض مصطلح العلمي
يشير الى عكس ضوء الشمس مثيره للتساؤل
نظريا هي واضحه تبدو ناجحه لكن كيف ستطبق
عمليا
نعم كما سمعتم بالبالونات المصنوعه من
ماده لا تاكسي سيتم اطلاقه ثلاثه منها في
الغلاف الجوي خلال
غير الحلي نعم التجربه بدات ويعول على ان
تنتج ما يصل الى 500 جرام من ثاني اكسيد
الكبريت نجاح التجربه تعميمها بجهود
عالميه سيخفض درجه حراره الارض درجه واحده
هناك من استخف بها كمبادله اداره المناخ
في كارنيجي ومن فكره جعل الغيوم اكثر
بياضا لكن الحلم في الغيوم قد يتحقق وقد
يمثل الخطوه الاولى الحقيقيه في تكنولوجيا
انعكاس ضوء الشمس ونتائجها ستظهر قريبا
عليها
مشاهدينا وصلنا الى نهايه موضوعاتنا لليوم
وتتابعونا غدا في الساعه 60 نجحته فاجنر
تشق الصفوف الروسيه من يكسب المعركه
الداخليه
مثاليه وتساعد وتنتجون يستعد
الذي
اشترى المهتدون
في نهايه الساعه ابرز واحداث الساعه في
صور من الان واحد تساعد المقبله انا حنين
السوري وهذه الساعه سته
[موسيقى]